c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir la création de deux zones
d'intérêt militaire au burkina faso
annonces du président de transition
paul-henri dany bas il a présidé hier un
conseil supérieur de défense ou des
décisions importantes ont été prises
kalidou sy vous en dira plus sur ses
décisions il est avec nous sur ce
plateau les détails dès le début de ce
journal ces manifestations à bankass
dans le centre du mali des dizaines de
personnes ont défilé pour réclamer la
protection de l'état après le massacre
de plus de 130 civils dans des villages
voisins un massacre attribué à des
djihadistes décryptage dans un instant
et puis ça durrmann échange de maillot
qui va jouer pour le bayern munich
l'international sénégalais va signer son
contrat et porter les couleurs du grand
club allemand les réactions à dakar à la
fin de ce film
[Musique]
le colonel paul henri damiba président
de la transition au burkina faso a
présidé hier un conseil supérieur de
défense ou des décisions importantes ont
été prises il a entre autres annoncé la
création de deux zones d'intérêt
militaire dans le nord du pays pour plus
d'information avec nous sur ce plateau
et kalidou sy bonsoir cali bonsoir je
rappelle à nos téléspectateurs que vous
étiez notre correspondant au burkina
faso et que vous avez couvert
l'actualité pendant plusieurs années
dans le pays kalidou en quoi consistent
ces zones d'intérêt militaire
effectivement le président damiba a
annoncé la création de deux zones
d'intérêt militaire dans le sahel et
l'est du pays pourquoi ces régions parce
que ce sont les régions les plus
touchées par les attaques terroristes
dans l'année donc concrètement c'est
quoi une zone d'intérêt militaire c'est
une zone de combat une zone de guerre et
d'ailleurs le président damiba et les
autorités burkinabè ont invité les
populations habitant dans ces zones à
quitter ces zones car ce sont des zones
de guerre il y aura beaucoup de combat
pour aller vers d'autres zones plus
paisible reste à savoir où et comment
parce que je vous rappelle qu'au burkina
faso il y à 2 millions de déplacés
internes ce qui représente 10% de la
population totale il ya aussi comme
annonce la création d'une bd paix une
brigade de veille de défense petro tic
qui regroupera l'ensemble des btp du
pays je vous rappelle ce que c'est les
bdp les bdp sont les volontaires de la
défense de la patrie ce sont des
supplétifs civil de l'armée
créée en 2019 pour intensifier les
actions contre les groupes terroristes
leur champ d'action sera principalement
le renseignement et l'opérationnel
dernière annonce désormais et c'est
nouveau d'ailleurs désormais il y aura
des sanctions qui peuvent aller du
disciplinaire au pénal contre les
militaires qui déserte en zone de combat
où les militaires qui aurait un mauvais
comportement envers les populations on
peut dire que c'est à demi mot une
il avoue à demi-mot que par le passé il
n'y a pu avoir des dérives comme des
exactions des forces de sécurité
burkinabè ou dvd paix contre les
populations des dérives qui ont été
documentés largement par des
organisations des droits de l'homme
comme amnesty international ou des
confrères qui ont fait beaucoup
d'articles sur ses dérives mais l'ancien
régime a toujours fermé les yeux dessus
et ses dérives
pour conséquence de briser la confiance
entre les populations et les forces de
sécurité et qui en a profité les groupes
terroristes car ils ont récupéré des
populations frustrées et donc on peut
dire que c'est le début d'une justice
sociale tant réclamé par les burkinabè
et je vous rappelle par exemple que lors
du massacre de ir booste un massacre
s'est déroulée le 1er et le 2 janvier
2019 plus d'une centaine de villageois
avaient été tués et jusqu'à maintenant
il n'y a pas eu de procès alors qu'ali
d'eau dans quel contexte rien de ces
annonces belle annonce intervient près
d'une semaine après l'attaqué terrible
de c'est un gars ou près de 86 personnes
selon un bilan officiel ont été tués une
attaque attribuée à l'état islamique
c'est l'une des attaques les plus
meurtrières du burkina faso ces
dernières années et tous les regards
sont désormais tournés vers le politique
en la personne du président damiba qui
je vous le rappelle lors du coup d'état
du 24 janvier dernier avait justifié ce
coup d'état par le fait que son
prédécesseur
roch marc christian kaboré et est en
incapacité de d'apporter la sécurité aux
burkinabè sur l'ensemble du territoire
donc près de six mois après le putsch le
président damiba est confronté
aujourd'hui un regain de violences qui a
fait plus de centaines des centaines de
victimes dans les régions du nord et du
sahel principalement et donc et donc
vous l'aurez compris le président damiba
est déjà sous pression alors justement
on va en parler du président damiba il a
rencontré aujourd'hui son prédécesseur
roch marc christian kaboré dont on avait
presque oublié qu'ils étaient toujours
privés de liberté effectivement le
président damiba a rencontré aujourd'hui
jean baptiste ouédraogo un ancien
président et roch marc christian kaboré
pour évoquer la transition et les
questions sécuritaires
rappelons que le président kaboré n'est
toujours pas libre il en résidence
surveillée bien qu'il ait pu regagner
son domicile familial c'était en avril
gagné et rappelons que le médiateur de
la cedeao pour le burkina faso mamadou
issoufou l'ancien président nigérien
était le week end année au burkina faso
il a exigé la libération immédiate de
l'ancien président kaboré rappelons
également que le prochain sommet de la
cedeao et le 3 juillet prochain à accra
voilà donc une rencontre sous la
pression de la cedeao merci beaucoup
kalidou sy pour votre d cryptage y
compris la colère des populations
civiles au mali des dizaines de
personnes ont manifesté mardi à bankass
dans le centre du pays pour réclamer la
protection de l'état après le massacre
de plus de 130 civiles attribuées à des
djihadistes dans des villages voisins où
la recherche de disparus se poursuit
encore écoutez l'analyse d'ousmane
diallo chercheurs afrique de l'ouest à
amnesty international
que 2016 il y à un cycle de violences
communautaires avec la montée de la
katiba massina donc et des représailles
qui ont eu lieu sur des membres de la
communauté peule a accusé d'être de
connivence avec la katiba matinale qui
ont entraîné un cycle de violences
intercommunautaires ont noté ni à des
représailles contre les populations
civiles dans le cercle de bankass fait
pas
par la katiba matinal ce qui est
relativement nouveau copain à l'état
islamique dans le grand sahara qui était
beaucoup plus ce qui est beaucoup plus
grands clans a attaqué les populations
civiles pour les vins timide et d'une
certaine manière comme on a pu le noter
au cours des derniers mois dans le cadre
de leur offensive dans la région de
ménaka mais aussi dans l'antichambre
watch dans la région de gao où des
centaines de civils aussi ont été tués
dans le cadre des attaques de l'état
islamique dans l'ombre
on reste dans le sahel au niger plus
précisément alors que quatre millions et
demi de personnes sont en insécurité
alimentaire le pam le programme
alimentaire mondial est contraint de
rationner les réfugiés toute la région
d'afrique de l'ouest et d'afrique de
l'est est concerné pourquoi cette
décision les explications d'aral girard
notre correspondant à niamey
les réfugiés ici au niger
particulièrement vulnérable en raison
des attaques à répétition contre les
populations eux aussi voient leur
situation alimentaire se dégrader au fil
de l'année alors même que dans le pays
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 4 millions de
personnes qui sont en situation
d'insécurité alimentaire
le pam n'a d'autre choix que de réduire
les rations de la quasi-totalité de ses
bénéficiaires les finances manquent est
déjà au début de l'année mais la guerre
en ukraine a capté une grande partie de
l'attention des principaux bailleurs de
fonds qui soutiennent l'action
humanitaire
aujourd'hui les réfugiés reçoivent 80 %
de la ration
ça nous a contraint à réduire leurs
rations à 80% et pour les autres
catégories donc les populations
déplacées internes et les communautés
hôtes on les contraint à 65% des rations
on fait tout cela avec beaucoup de
mécontentement mais on est obligé de le
faire pour pouvoir assister plus grande
partie des personnes qui sont dans le
besoin cette année au niger la période
de soudure la période la plus critique
au niveau alimentaire entre la fin des
récoltes de l'année dernière et le début
des nouvelles de cette année 2022 est
prévu pour durer deux fois plus
longtemps qu'à l'accoutumée c'est à dire
six mois de ce mois de juin jusqu'au
moins de novembre prochain le programme
alimentaire mondial a annoncé que pour
revenir à une situation d'équilibré et
fournir toutes les populations
bénéficiaires à 100% des rations
auxquels elles ont droit l'organisme
aurait besoin de 46 millions de dollars
supplémentaires cette année
le cercueil de patrice lumumba quitté
bruxelles aujourd'hui et va arriver
prochainement à kinshasa au lendemain de
la remise par la belgique d'une relique
du corps de l'ancien premier ministre de
la république démocratique du congo
assassiné en 1961 l'occasion pour les
congolais de belgique de célébrer une
dernière fois leur héros national sur
une place bruxelloise qui porte son nom
depuis 2018 l'occasion aussi pour les
associations qui se battent pour sa
mémoire depuis des années de marquer
cette étape décisive écouter
progrès très important parce qu'il ya
quatre ans quand on a mis en place cette
bref le monde
il ya beaucoup de monde de la famille
qui n'ont pas pu venir passer des fêtes
bizarre leur relation n'était pas bonne
et aujourd'hui toute la famille est
présente le premier ministre a eu un
discours extraordinaire leroy également
le premier ministre du congo également
donc je pense qu'il ya eu des messages
forts entre les deux pays je ne voudrais
pas qu'il s'agit simplement d'une
certaine hypocrisie parce que par
exemple je suis étonné que l'on restitue
la dent après 60 ans mais sont que ce
soit sans que l'on puisse organiser
pratiquement un procès qui nous clarifie
pratiquement sur les différentes
responsabilités leur permettent je pense
à l'âme et l'esprit de monsieur mba de
reposer en paix mais pour nous le moment
n'est pas entraîné non comme tout ça à
faire il ya des combats à mener en
justice contre les mines dans les rues
d'autres compagnies au parlement et on
va vraiment si l'ordinateur le maximum
du boulot et voilà pourquoi elle va pas
arrêter
vaut mieux la sincérité du piment quelle
hypocrisie du sucre alors je me demande
un peu pourquoi avoir un temps attendu
longtemps pour faire ce genre de
manifestation c'est vrai que c'est avec
beaucoup de peine mais le plus important
mieux vaut tard que jamais dit on ils
ont quand même accepter ça soulage nos
coeurs nous qui obtient en panne et à
l'époque
aujourd'hui on peut aussi dire que mes
sur le mont bavard reposer en paix voilà
propos recueillis par notre
correspondante à bruxelles alix le
bourdon la saison des pluies en côte
d'ivoire et son lot de catastrophes
abidjan a été durement touchée dans la
nuit de lundi à mardi au moins cinq
personnes dont quatre enfants sont
mortes dans des inondations après une
nuit de pluie torrentielle un bilan des
pompiers qui ont été mobilisés dans les
nombreux quartiers de la capitale
économique ivoirienne
les précisions tonnes correspondant
samuel bernard
à travers toute la ville chaque quartier
a sa propre histoire des éboulements de
terrain des voitures emportées par les
eaux des voix inaccessible là où nous
sommes rendus c'est un mur anti
inondation qui a cédé les habitants ont
été surpris à 5h 6h du matin avec un
niveau atteignant plus d'un mètre à
l'intérieur donc de leur maison écoutez
leurs témoignages levet bateau n'est
guère étonné on sait pas quoi faire et
bon comme ça vous vous appuyez où sékou
sauter sauter bon accouchèrent la côte
est assez dit et dans ce sens nous
sommes échappés c'était comme ça on
avait dit à fait sorti les enfants parce
que nous on voit que la pluie du lait
donc on s'est dit que vraiment il faut
plein des propositions
la journée s'est déroulée au rythme des
mauvaises nouvelles en milieu donc de
journée les autorités ont annoncé le
décès de quatre enfants à notre arrivée
dans le quartier donc de bingerville
c'est le corps d'un conducteur de taxi
qui était retrouvé des morts qui
auraient pu être évitées selon les
habitants en particulier dans pro cette
femme que nous avons interrogés dont la
maison a été inondée pour elle les
autorités pourraient mieux anticiper ces
épisodes de plus comme on nous le
comprenons pas nous on s'est dit puis un
silence franchement c'est pas quel
niveau mais il faut que le dossier soit
payant mais parce qu'en nous des moments
de bouger des gens ont acheté des
maisons plusieurs sont à la retraite
quand comment ils vont faits sont
obligés de rester sur les lieux faute de
dispositifs anti-inondations efficace
des autorités privilégient souvent des
évacuations définitive début juin elles
ont d'ailleurs annoncé un grand plan
d'évacuation du concerne 25000 carson
mais pour l'heure aucune proposition de
relogement ne leur a été proposé
et avant de fermer ce journal cette
information qui intéresse les fans de
football c'est officiel sadio man et
quitte le club anglais de liverpool pour
signer chez les allemands du bayern
munich
la star sénégalaise est arrivé ce
mercredi matin à munich pour signer son
contrat et passer sa visite médicale son
transfert estimé à 40 millions d'euros
est très bien accueillie au sénégal la
correspondance des limes ndao
70 % des sénégalais veulent que je
quitte liverpool je ferai ce qu'il
souhaite c'est là des propos de sayouba
n'est tenu lors du dernier rassemblement
de l'équipe nationale du sénégal de
football devant les journalistes un
signal au bayern munich 5e année vient
d'une certaine manière de satisfaire à
une demande populaire il est considéré
comme une légende absolue du football
sénégalais surtout depuis la dernière
victoire du sénégal à la coupe d'afrique
des nations et ce penalty victorieux à
face à l'egypte sa gamme année jouit
d'une forte cote de popularité auprès
des sénégalais qui a prouve son choix
écoutez c'est une très bonne chose dans
la mesure où son contrat avec liverpool
est arrivé à expiration est comme le
king du bien aussi si j'ai une très
bonne équipe et je pense que c'est un
bon choix
pour
gagner et joue pour gagner il doit la
base il fait et voir encore donc
j'espère qu'on lui va mieux là bas c'est
le gars au sénégal tout ce qu'on lui
souhaite le meilleur pour lui parce que
vraiment il le mérite il est notre
fierté vraiment frais - on le suit tous
les maires du monde vraiment il le
mérite
après avoir tout gagné à liverpool 1-1
de versailles omanais se fixent cette
saison de nouveaux objectifs parmi
lesquels la bundesliga le championnat
allemand de football tout comme la ligue
des champions est espérée par faisant
une bonne coupe du monde en fin d'année
avec le sénégal peut-être de gagner le
ballon d'or le trophée récompensant le
meilleur joueur de football au monde
voilà et vous pourrez toujours compter
sur notre champion et limane dao pour
vous donner des nouvelles de ses adieux
manie c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de parent isolé
[Musique]